Maybe you're trying to figure out how to get
started and move fast on a specific business
or technology problem, or maybe you have
a long list of projects already in mind,
but you need help prioritizing
and accelerating. Fortunately,
IBM Garage is here to help, and our no-charge
Framing Session is a perfect first step!
In just a few short hours, teams are
able to rapidly brainstorm and identify
their highest-impact, business
opportunities and define
plus align around which are the
highest-value one to immediately pursue.
This all happens in a highly-collaborative,
facilitated virtual session that uses
Enterprise Design Thinking Principles
along with IBM Garage Methodology to ensure
incredibly successful outcomes, fast.
Let's explore just how we are able to do all of
that through our IBM Garage Framing Sessions:
Each Framing Session consists of roughly
5-7 participants from your organization;
including key stakeholders from Business, IT,
and the like. Having a diverse range of opinions
and perspectives from key decision
makers is really essential at this stage.
From our side, we bring in an Enterprise Design
Thinking Facilitator - like myself
- and a Garage Solution Architect,
along with the right team of subject matter
experts, picked specifically for your session,
to ensure we can help identify meaningful Business
Opportunities no matter your domain or industry.
Throughout this very engaging, interactive
session, we perform a number of tailored
activities which act as a funnel,
allowing us to go from brainstorming
all the possible opportunities we could
explore to prioritization of the ones
with the most potential business value and
finally aligning around and framing the right,
highest impact Business
Opportunity to rapidly pursue.
To make virtual collaboration truly a breeze, we
like to use an amazing online whiteboarding tool
that allows everyone to generate
and modify content in real time!
From creating sticky notes,
adding images, voting and so
much more - there's something truly magical and
energizing about seeing the flurry of cursors
at work as we swiftly populate activities and
drive towards incredible outcomes together!
In nearly no time at all, we
have rapid alignment of top
stakeholders around exactly what we should pursue
and the actionable next steps to drive towards it;
kicking off your journey and giving you
an incredible headstart - all at no cost.
Best of all, continuing the journey with
IBM Garage is just as easy: With Garage,
you have options like focused Garage
education to jumpstart your teams,
or you can dive right in with an
IBM Garage Design Thinking Workshop
and Minimum Viable Product Build - enabling you
to achieve your framed, priority project, fast.
IBM Garage is able to bring an
incredible unparalleled experience,
a real end-to-end partnership and true,
speed-to-value success for every project
all while partnering with you each step of the way
and enabling you on our best-in-class methodology.
Visit ibm.com/garage today to learn more about
IBM Garage and schedule your
no-charge, Framing Session!